I have a question which big chest event
is starting this week yes the World
Chess Championship and hold the players
yes
Magnus Carlsen is one and he's staying
in India so most likely playing against
an Indian player right who is best
Indian player you don't know the name of
the world champion my goodness yes
that's correct that's what you were
going to say actually I was pointing to
you but I did add he took this one yes
and none from India is the is the world
champion basically since 2007 you want
the tournament that was it had all the
best players in the world in Mexico City
if I'm not mistaken 2007 then he
defended pretty much against everyone so
that's really remarkable in 2008 he
defended against Vladimir Kramnik and
kramnik is known to beaten who who did
comic bit in a match maybe the greatest
wrestlers of all times
he beat Kasparov in 2010 image button on
beat him in 2008 then in 2010 he bit at
that time was considered the best or
second best player in the world to Paulo
in 2012 actually because of some tiny
bizarre system he bit not one of the
very best players in the world but still
let's say one of the top 10 15 players
in the world boys girl fan that made it
somehow to the final but now oh I don't
think ever in history pretty much was a
world champion I really think it's the
most was a world champion such an
underdog I mean no I I just out of quick
thinking never in history maybe kappa
blanka Lasker in 1921 that's quite a
long time that last year was such a big
underdog but
madness Carson which you maybe maybe for
a reason you know you knew who is
playing but you didn't know the world
champion we can obviously take book and
discuss parcel and tactics and all those
things but you know what we're going to
have eleven month after following the
oneness of the World Championship to do
it day and night but for the World
Championship we're going to give them
respect and we go on a tiny bit see
their games so what about the ages who
is younger magnus Carson or not they are
about 22 years apart I believe I believe
an ant is born in 68 and Carson in 1990
so there's a very big gap maybe on on 60
60 I think 68 maybe 69 but really really
very very big gap between them so Carson
is 23 years old and 944 5 so we'll see
how this met rolling this game that we
will start played about five years ago
it is played in a rapid tournament that
was played in Mainz in Germany at that
time and none was just tiny less than an
ounce waiting right we can see there
waiting Anand is 2798 and Carson 2775
the interesting part is that Anand
rating is very similar to what it was
then 27:17 these days actually is lowest
rating pretty much I would say in the
last 8 years I believe since two
thousand four or five he hasn't been
that low maybe temporarily but Carlsen
far far far above anyone else with 2870
broke Kasparov area code so really big
changes Carson is hundred points higher
than this match this gaming and and a
bit list so let's start with will will
give one game for one and and then one
game for Carson a bit more recent one
etho what's the name of this opening yes
duh yes
Sicilian I can get that night if three
now many many many versions to play here
but we will look at this game this is
the open Sicilian because white
immediately play d4 and open the center
and here there are two really major
continuations a6 which was a big favor
of two of the greatest world champions
Bobby Fischer and Kasparov the night of
Defense and g6 that was also played a
bit by coz power actually in the match
against Anand I matched it was in United
States the biggest event ever I think at
least in the United States a World
Championship match which took part in
1995 in New York because power played
their dragons several times there okay
so the dragon Bishop e3 okay we will
stop here for a second okay so we have
castling in actually opposite castling
right look black black castles King side
and white Queen side short castle or
long castle or King side and Queen side
white shot because the rook only moves
two squares and here the rook moves
twist goes right always the King moved -
doesn't matter
always the King moves - sometimes they
work moves - sometimes they work moves
three okay what is usually the character
of a game that involves opposite castles
yes
why what that's correct why would we
usually have a more aggressive game that
involved much more attacking when the
Kings our castle to opposite direction
it's too now let's think about the logic
can someone tell me
but why would it be attacking
because I agree but why I have saying
that they will try to get the Kings I
agree you're very very quick but why why
what would be the logic behind it yes
there are different sides of the board
and this enables you to be able to do
what to push the pawns that enables you
to push the pawns
if White King was on the Kings side it
wouldn't be that easy for him to push
the pawns right because then he would be
weakening his King but right now white
wants to push those pawns and black
would make effort to play here by the
way what is the idea of pushing the
pawns when the opponent Castle to death
sighs what do we really want to do we
want to push the pawns and what will be
the goal of pushing the pawns but we're
gonna push the pawns on this side
no no no we are not going to promote I
mean you don't push the spawn with the
intention of having the pawn on h8 not
gonna happen
no but the idea of pushing the pawns is
to open lines and files basically I mean
the Kings are both well defended right
now both of the Kings are well defended
but I pathetically if both of those
pawns disappear well let us say black
does nothing
I will just just to demonstrate here
this is very very identical to the
position we just had seconds ago only
that what happened the H file has been
open and guess what who is next to the H
file black Kings black king so we opened
files to have access to attack the King
for example this would be an excellent
to move here already now we have ideas
for checkmate let's say black place
again same thing ignores white taketake
how do we play Czech material yes
this one okay Queenie J this what
happens when you open files it gives you
access to attack the King if there is no
access to attack the King and this is in
one line really one line the logic of
opposite castles you can push pawns the
opponent can do the same y you can push
pause because your Kings are not on the
same side so you can push pawns in order
to make to open files and then get
access to the King I mean look it's
exactly the same position but black is
actually already lost here like it's
lost here while this position is
theoretical and being played by many of
the best players in history this
position totally okay take away the
h-bond
black and resign resign you don't
believe me let's see let's look at this
position if we put just just to get an
idea what the computer will think about
it let's put a computer for a second
he says the position is about equal no
no big change right so it's not really
important anything more than that okay
now let's go to our position where we
have exactly the same thing but we just
opened the file do you think it's going
to be more than a quarter point for
white it's going to be many many many
points for white black is lost four
points black is lost lost which means
white is up four points of material
actually I think it should be even more
I mean black is lost just because we did
one thing we opened a file so this is
the idea of our opposite castles 95 was
played King b1 well very very simple
move moving at the King away form they
work right
just move the King tiny bit away a
what does black wanna do win but why did
he play six how do they think we're
gonna help him win yes
but but why why black play this movie
wants to push pause buying stuff right
it's not like white invented something
only you can use it okay apparently
Anand also been in this class and he
knows how to play so he played h4 o the
opposite we study from him and that's
our way okay but Carlson played exactly
that idea in order to prevent and now
the game goes into very very complicated
territory too complicated we will just
follow it tiny bit so white made F
wanted to open the H file and black
block it but well white is not backing
away G for so many times in those types
of positions you cannot be afraid to
sacrifice little bit material and I use
the word sacrifice when you lose
material do you have compensation when
you lose material no that's why the
definition of lose you don't get
anything in return when you sacrifice at
least you want to say hey I give you a
pawn or two pawns or whatever but I get
something in return
so Anand wants to get exactly well they
open G file the open H file is willing
to give a pawn another pawn maybe
sometimes way more in those positions
take
not a surprise right well is rook aiming
those files that we keep mentioning
again and again and again okay
Queen to a5 was played I believe man
they add some recent some recent tea
over here I think some don't even
remember what they were playing here
mouki eighties in some lines a move here
Queen a5 Bishop eight-six who can tell
me what is the purpose of this move yes
Ari
which defender very very good to remove
this defender just immediately around
the king this bishop defending all those
important squares over there so if we
want to have a successful attack what we
should do well get rid of the opponent
defenders right the bishop on g7 is a
huge defender and actually white as they
already a very big threat here why does
the threat to let a black place this
move for example just a meaningless move
white has a big threat already he can
maybe take immediately but also take and
white is threatening checkmate and if
the knight moves well white can take the
Queen for free white can might even take
the knight or not no I know yes no yes
yes no can I take denied their porn
right the pawn is pinned that's actually
one of the big ideas why we get the
bishop out so this is an idea or taking
the Queen this pin this type of pin
those types of pins they are very very
important for the pawn so already big
attacking big attack for white here I
think when a five is a bad move but okay
rook takes Knight very similar play by
Anand and already very very big well the
threat is just Queen to h6 and win the
game so cause black is already lost here
because white managed to basically break
through first very classical game of
opposite castles now let's see let's
walk together what happens if black take
the rook we always have to see what
about capturing material what happen if
we take the walk what is that we will
make it move by move what is the first
move to consider here for white no Queen
g5 excellent let's see something kin the
night block what happens if the night
block now we cannot take the knight
because the king is not in but what will
we play yes
perfect okay good
so black is moving is king we will take
move the pawn go back and now art good
move
yes here I like it also this is why we
open files you see no defendants no
pawns that are stopping it this is why
we open files so that's the problem of
black there that is blacks problem
Carson went for some desperation idea he
sacrifice this Queen should do I take
the luke or not whenever you can capture
something of your opponent whenever you
have to ask yourself should i what is my
opponent planning not just say oh wow my
opponent he just gave me a rook go party
no I mean maybe if it really made a
mistake but you have to really anything
carefully consider what is gonna play
don't only think about your moves right
so what happens if white takes the book
should he take the book yes no maybe
could be we'll see no definitely no you
want to change your answer we could see
the think again okay what will happen if
you take the book exactly would you
believe that Anand also seen that you
don't believe that a nun could see that
he saw that right
because if take very good then this is
at least an idea all the whitest I think
is still gonna be I think still white is
going to be just winning this was played
and then he attack the night because he
can still not take the rook now remember
if the knight goes here
we're gonna do the same trick check the
king go check and we're gonna check
meeting okay what to play here with why
should we take the night or their Bishop
what should we play
the bishop the night Bishop Knight yes
the bishop what would happen if we take
the knight what is Blair gonna play
let's say we take the knight what is
they gonna play
yes exactly and the bishop is defending
and suddenly I think black is better
well yes beautiful white as a knight up
but what is the price for this Knight
two pawns one two three four five six
seven five pawns yuck
black is winning here five pawns that's
too much for a night but do we think
that a nun missed that not really cause
he took the bishop and now he's just
winning so how did I not win the game he
had a very strong attack
they didn't lead to a checkmate it's
really important that we understand
strong players very very rarely get
checkmated how games are really being
won
are they how chess games are being won
ah I couldn't hear you what you said it
no no no yeah all those big
philosophical strategy practically how
do we win chess game you have been a
week in our camp my goodness they will
fire me even before I'm hired you don't
remember
we win yes yes but how do we get to that
how do practically on the board winning
the game yes a strong attack but it's
leading to what thank you winning
material that's how we really win chess
games exactly exactly black was in
center-aligned getting checkmated but
stomp nerves very very very rarely get
checkmated what really happens is they
defend the only question is what is the
cost of defending you let's say
sacrifice a knight then your opponent
has to return a bishop in a pawn is not
checkmated but you are a pawn that's
really what happened sacrifice many
situations and then the defender has to
give back more material winning material
pretty much it can be a pawn it can be a
knight
usually it's not that much but here yeah
white is that material
he has a queen for a rook and three
pawns but black king is also weak it's
still not that easy to win him and then
could have played actually better before
but he managed to get and win this game
he's targeting the black king and now
take take and which good move here for
white yes take the work what did we did
we say that when we did we think that
when we gonna play something we're going
to think about the opponent move so if
you take his work maybe we'll take your
win you're not gonna be that happy check
the king well check was possible but
Anand wanted to eliminate those
connected pawns you know we wanted to
eliminate the connected pawns so he took
one pawn is going to take another pawn
so how do so how is white winning
checkmate material and the more we
remember it the better chess player we
will be okay bringing the King
bringing the King now he has a passport
and that pass pawn is going to cause
black his walk run that's it this was
the moment a turn and resign so we have
seen a very very nice game between them
well Toby Carlsen resign thank you
someone is listening very good very good
Carson resign well yeah I mean in my
head I was thinking about the imagine
well we're probably gonna see more not
resign but this was five years ago at
that time I think that while Alan was
probably a better player than Carson at
that time I mean an and was
I would say the match would come it was
really a great match fo and nan but
Carlson like we said at that time was
just 18 amazing
so now five years old five years after
he's coming as a huge favorite Carlson
has a style if we have to speak about
styles and none style is both both of
those players have a very universal
style I mean they can play solid
positions they can attack they can play
complicated oh well they are the best
best players in the world still everyone
has is well type that he is better more
or less in an and sometimes played the
most complicated positions out there
because he can is amazing amazing
calculating and use great memory I mean
both of them are super geniuses Carson
is tiny bit leaning to the other side
you can play everything amazing that way
is by far the number one player in the
world but still is big strength these
days is playing actually very solid
positions if we said that we can win
games by winning material this is one
really type the other one is just
getting most pace let's see this one
played pretty much exactly two years
after the 2008 match and we can already
see that if I'm not mistaken in the
previous one Anand was 2798 okay he made
two points in two years it's not so much
now he's actually a bit less but Carson
already improved fifty points it was
twenty seven 75 already here is clearly
number one in the world so playing in a
tournament by the way where is Carson
form which country none from India no it
is from Norway and then quite quite
amazing that no way that doesn't have
any big huge I get in your chest
tradition not at all
somehow has amazing amazing player the
best player in the world
no ok so Carlton is white
'if Oh usually if Oh has tiny bit more
aggressive approach when we start the
game with evolve it means that we want
tiny bit more to attack usually the
nature of the game is more attacking
when we start the game with default it's
usually more positional and we want to
conquer space I mean of course they are
very complicated lines with d4 and very
very simple and solid lines with a foe
but the general terms it would be more
playing for space ok does anyone know
the name of this opening when with you
and chat of the bishop yes daddy no quiz
Gabi decline is when we went black plays
d5 in e6 yes the which one I think it
Kings Indian against d4 that's how it's
called King's Indian can transposed to
some lines in other opening called
grunsfeld bataki alright
very decent place for black white black
immediately wants to challenge and fight
for which squares which squares black is
fighting for the central squares right
which is very very important for us to
be able to control the square the center
right okay now many this was this
position was actually played in Karpov
Kasparov two world champions that
actually came before
well Kasparov we mentioned lost two
Kramnik and then whatever stories well
but tiny bit before an and and Karpov
came after Fischer so several games were
between Karpov and Kasparov in this line
were actually their cup of took Knight
c3 were the version they played actually
a very good memories from this opening
in the World Championship under 16 that
I want I played this with white in the
last round actually and I had to win so
that's quite nice memories and I took
and played 93 and somehow 192 ok
Bishop f5 getting the bishop out
developing the night okay taketake
nothing dramatic is happening they just
exchanged tiny bit black is fighting for
the center nothing too much very very
different type of game from before right
before what it was opposite castle and
immediately everyone is tile is trying
their punches hill very very slow white
one might say has microscopic advantage
why is that because he has those two
pawns as opposed to as opposed to black
those two so white has two central pawns
and black has only one central pawn and
one tiny behind but if it all
microscopic advantage but for the world
number one that's what he wants to play
with microscopic advantage and he is
world number one maybe you can make
something out of it walk to d8 look to D
1 where are we going to put the books on
the center of us well we believe that
the files will be open does anyone
believe that the F file right now is
going to be open but why do we why we
believe that those files might be open
because the pawns are touching one
another right the pawns are touching one
another
97 Queen f5 is anything really exciting
happening no but that's how Karsten
that's death this game shows Carlsen
style in the best way nothing nothing
microscopic advantage and at some point
tiny bit out playing his opponent by the
way what's the logic of oak d2 YY to
play ugly - yes
little bit yes I agree another thing
another reason fogged it oh yes what
perfect perfect
very good the night was pinned right we
want to break the pins right we want to
put more pressure when we are pinning
opponent pit and we want to get out of
pins when we can right so very logical
move tiny be to double the rules but
much more just so a nun plays very solid
it took because this world I think it
threat for white white wanted to put his
night on this pretty screw okay so we
can tiny bit speak about strategy white
is pair of bishops black doesn't pair of
bishops are not bad right because they
can control a lot of squares but look
what a nun did very smartly a nun gave
is light color bishop so where does he
put all his pawns
we're all black pawns light colors
exactly to basically replace the bishop
that he doesn't have he doesn't have a
bishop to fight for the light colors i
just marked them too so but he put all
his pawns on light colors so they can
control this those areas the light
colored area which which bishop is left
dark one the bishop is totally not
blocked so they are complementing one
another the pawns on light squares the
bishop that is left is dark squares to
be horrible if it was the other way then
what would he have to fight for the
lights was nothing and his bishop would
be blocked so once again this position
use the WC play like Magnus but this is
such still small advantage because black
is so solid the black have any
weaknesses does this King weak
this King week does he have and nothing
just white is tiny pair of Bishops a foe
well many moves will be played here at
five still controlling all the light
squares Queen back a five I'm not
certain
totally about this move but one idea
that white wanted to do was to play c5
let it like that nothing white wants to
start getting more space c5 in advance
and then prepare maybe shift the books
to the B file and have this break full
so if you look at this position White's
real advantage or tiniest is he has more
space material Penal equal just tiny bit
no space deep this is how best players
in the world play many grandmasters
there is no oh a blunder a queen no know
what happening or under a night not
happening
checkmate it not so much of course
everyone blunders but one out of I don't
know how many games but those type of
games happen a lot bishops III what is
the threat of bishops III
yes
but simple threat bishops III what is
the threat of this move it has a simple
threat yes re to take it not yet attack
and take it right exactly if white if
you try to play will just take it
immediately
okay take take take okay so something
happened tiny bit I don't like this move
on a five by an ant but what happened
here the central pawns have been removed
this big drop looks tiny bit more open
right I have a question
bishops do you have a question also when
the position open would it favor the one
with the pair of bishops or not if you
have two pair of bishops or if you have
a bishop just 102 would you prefer the
position to be more closed or more open
yes
open wide open that's the big difference
that were really the difference between
the bishop and the knight can't seem to
play look in this position how active is
this bishop it's really blocked in this
one if you remove the central pawns you
know the same remember before when we
were speaking about attack and we say
hey let's move the pulse from the files
and see how weak it is for black we will
do the same here we will say let's take
dif this and this and let's take both
ways we remove the e D and C pawn all
black is in huge trouble because white
bishops will control the entire board
this is why this is already a bit nicer
for white I can see that this [ __ ] this
diagonal is not as closed as it used to
be which of a fate the target is
this book
why didn't Enclave okay seven so the
pond will be defended taketake I I
wonder if he could maybe play here maybe
there's some reason why to play that to
me Bishop city looks looks quite logical
actually I'm not hundred percent certain
why not bishops victory no I'm gonna be
amazing computer like this of Satori
tiny more yeah
Bishop City makes no sense but okay not
arguing with Carsten but I would play
Bishop c3 okay be sure before take take
96 okay how is carlson style playing
slow weakness after weakness tiny tiny
bit look how many moves the game lasted
fifty five most many many of the games
that he wins are long games like no no
immediate knockouts okay why why did he
play quincy to here yes i be perfect
perfect because chess is a game of what
material protecting and attacking okay
but you still need to find a way to
attack this one let's look at this game
a bit evo okay
black has a little weakness but it's
perfectly defended what's the purpose of
this movie for if someone can tell me
exactly i want to hear the exact word
what is the purpose of this movie for
anyone there should be three words to
describe afore yes rd control their
center those are three words not
horrible not the one that I'm looking
for but not horrible yes
attack tonight that's actually a threat
agree that's actually a threat something
else yes just saying hi yes daddy
three words it starts with open open the
position open the position look this is
a bishop last time I checked this is a
knight it's tiny bit too close here you
know if you start to removing pawns take
this this do take those two and those
two away oh what's going to be so happy
but that's exactly what Carson is going
to do so we open tiny bit this diagonal
remove the F pawn and this is a weakness
so they'll basically we see in the two
games that we have two different
approaches in how to play chess one go
and attack and play very aggressive go
after your opponent King the other one
is okay you know let's create a weakness
and play slowly and create another
weakness entity there is no better or no
better
it's basically depends on the class
qualities so let's see what under attack
now after Queen b3
the pawn on e6 King at seven for example
I wonder if it's a bit tricky but I want
to see if someone can tell me didn't
Anand the world champion see that he can
take the pawn attack the Queen and even
the knight defense he didn't see that
you think oh they do see that he did so
I didn't play that yes the book will
take the knight they actually several
moves to play here for white that I
think are really strong one is to play
this move attacking the knight and
attacking here but I think but I think
the best move is just take and suddenly
black is left without any defenses
something like this I take oh goodness
there is a walk on the other side so
maybe Queen this way actually I was
thinking if this is a winning attacker I
actually overlooked that tiny look over
there yeah then maybe just quindi three
simple and targeting the night and the
g6 and the g6 pawn that that might be
just a different possibility any good
one so he bought the King to defense
okay well now now he needs to protect
our Clifty of thinking about protecting
this one so the knight is a great outfit
very very positional play the work was
under attack and rookie 5 some ideas of
sacrificing and breaking through already
there Knight back three seven defending
and Carlsen sacrifice so after a long
long positional play in battle finally
white is managed to win upon exchange
works and here is the question if take
this was actually actually interesting
possibility but they think it is not
gonna work for Oh actually how how
should white play here very very pretty
he's gonna play check and now I have a
question if whites gonna take the hook
immediately what is black onyx play that
will have a very good movie white will
take their work immediately
yes Rd Queen where defy fight
that's your move 2525 so which really
really smart move those white have you
actually might actually yeah several
possibilities to win you know yes
we'll get four is an excellent move what
what type of mood okay for B then
intermediate move before we going to
capture we first gonna move the rook in
a forcing way check
and actually this would even be stronger
check that's what you check and now move
the look so now check again for example
and then move the walk and completely
crush black so we are not tempted to
take immediately because of Queen define
okay and then play check first
but now weak pawn weak pawn weak pawn
how many pawn islands does black have
sorry right one pawn island to three
white is one - I know how to count that
your help is very helpful okay so black
king is tiny weak and pawn structure
looky fall okay what's the idea of h5
no this point is not going to make it to
a queen but why did we see we mentioned
before tiny bit pushing the pawn what is
the idea
move away this pawn and open route for
the out pieces exactly exactly move away
and open ways for remove of the
defendant around the King okay finally
after all this big game two things
happen one White is a pawn but even more
importantly black king is totally weak
of course we could have seen this game
much much much much slower but oh it why
did black who is like ace Queen is under
attack
the material is equal right now but let
me sign on and resign is queen is under
attack what's going to happen when he's
going to move the screen
exactly exactly
very very good the knight would be
captured and if the Queen doesn't go
away then white will be winning material
exactly okay those were two games to
have you tiny be think about well both
though both of those players Carlsen
doesn't really play very very big
attacking games he has some but not
really nude usually those type of games
or much more relying on positional Anand
played everything both very big
attacking games many positional games
huge favorite Carson for the match